hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
someone that does not like kevin samuels
the video is titled
kevin samuels value system is [ __ ]
now i've never seen the video so i have
no idea what like the counter argument
is but i think it's only fair
because i've reacted to kevin samuels
some stuff i agreed with some stuff i
disagreed with
and i i kind of found myself in the
middle so i think it would be
interesting to like see if i agree with
somebody that doesn't
like him so
[Music]
okay but before i start do not forget to
like comment and subscribe
especially subscribe guys i'm trying to
get to 15 000 subscribers that's gonna
be my next big milestone
and do not forget to also follow me on
instagram
a lot of these videos are submitted to
me through instagram so if you have a
video that you want me to react to
dm it to me on instagram i always check
my dms so if it's a video that i think
would do well on this channel i'll
definitely respond
and i will react to it so let me
click scene two okay
so this lady just starting
i'm just not a fan of the outfit or the
hair
but um
i heard this little old daddy kevin
sandman samuels he over here talking
[ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about the black woman
now why would he do that i heard him say
that
uh a black woman with a child
is low value excuse the [ __ ] out of me
cause that means that baby your mama was
low value the minute she
stuffed your fat thick head through her
[ __ ]
it's not low value though
like that's not what he's saying what
he's saying is that that's a lot to ask
somebody that doesn't know you so
you might be a high value person and
that's great
but if somebody is just gonna like
before they date you they don't know you
at
all so if on paper you're somebody that
has
kids raising someone else's
kid is a lot to ask anyone you feel me
what happened to you baby do you have a
bad relationship with your mama did she
do something to you
was she a single mother and put men
before you
huh did she i hate arguments like this
it's not a real argument but your [ __ ]
up situations let you get touched to
something
what happened because now you look at
black woman
as if having a child is a bad thing
honey the minute that that person went
to 10 centimeters she turned into a
goddess
a goddess when a woman bursts a human
being are you crazy
but again that's not what he says at all
he says that
that's a lot to ask somebody
i mean he might have used those words
he's pretty harsh but i understand like
what he's talking about like he's saying
that that is a lot to ask a man to raise
another person's child
and i think that's a lot to ask a woman
too i think more women are willing to do
it than men
but like either way that's a lot to ask
baby it's yourself crazy you sound crazy
and sound broken
and now you a mascot to all the broken
[ __ ] out there
huh that's being done wrong or some [ __ ]
so now you don't even find
value in a woman
and a woman that has a child at a single
mother what
okay i don't think that people are
valuable just for being like a person
like i don't think a woman's
okay everybody has a certain dignity
because they come from god
but if i don't know you how am i
supposed to know what value you bring to
me if i don't know you
and people are allowed to discriminate
on who they want to date
and i want to say that's closer i don't
think kevin samuels is religious but i
want to say that's closer to its message
and i think what she
is picking up somebody that's out here
hustling and doing it
by theirself is it that you just don't
have the capacity to love like that
you can't love other people's children
because you don't you are shallow
baby your spirit is shallow you don't
have love in your deep
is that what it is that's not
most of us has been raised by another
person
baby that's helped along the way ain't
nothing
ain't no love lost now you keep talking
[ __ ]
it's calling us low valued and all that
[ __ ] we go i'm gonna have a problem when
i see you
yes spongebob squarehead ass [ __ ] huh
the minute i see you with that turtle
i'm gonna wrap that [ __ ] around that
turtleneck [ __ ]
show you what a woman do sorry
oh dear
this i feel like this lady it's like one
ear out the other
look at there's stuff about some kevin
samuels that i seriously like don't
agree with i don't think that
that everything he says is a good
message but
like that's not what he's saying at all
like that's literally not what he's
saying he's not even saying
he's just being honest when it comes to
dating
like a kid for anyone is a lot
to talk about or a lot to ask of someone
especially someone that doesn't know you
so anyways just my two cents let me know
in the comments if you agree
or disagree don't forget to like comment
and subscribe
i'll talk to you guys next time